what is it about Grace and about this
movie that appealed to you that that
Drew you to it uh being anxious a lot
you know sitting in the movie theater by
yourself and you you know and that's
kind of me in a way you know and
it's harder to connect I think for some
people you know so that really it was I
love that opening for that and then
um it changes with the the movie changes
with time and it's kind of great because
she has an opportunity to develop into
something more free-spirited as opposed
to being anxious or did you agree with
that I did I did I also really liked
that um of all of the parents in the
movie She's sort of also felt like the
most hopeful in terms of love like she
had the the most positive elements yeah
yeah
speaking of rom-coms and I guess romance
generally um you are such a staple of
the genre and I want to know what it is
about this kind of story if if that's
not your outlook generally then what is
it about this kind of story that
resonates so much
um you know for me it's uh I have to
feel like I'm just it's usually pretty
much I'm doing me
but then I'm in these situations that
are really wonderful like I love the
theater I love the walk and talk after
the theater I love
um you know scenes with the uh where
there was the big fight scenes and I
just enjoy it I just really enjoy it you
know I went to
I went to acting school when I was young
the neighborhood Playhouse with Sandy
Meisner who is like such a great
um he really did give me so much and
thou you know these things happen in our
lives sometimes we get lucky like that
you know and sometimes you don't and I
he was really the reason that I have the
opportunity to start and begin to act in
scenes on stage you know I was in hair
oh yeah give me down to their hair
singing that it was ridiculous but it
was great because it was the first time
I was ever on a stage in New York ever
so it's been a really interesting life
regarding that the work and how it it
changes with time and what you do at one
time maybe you let it go and you move on
so of your body of work then if somebody
were coming to work for the first time
where would you suggest that you start
you know it all depends on them you know
it's how do they um I guess you know for
the most part we all have to audition so
it's all about that audition and I
remember that audition that I had my
first audition it was like blew me out
of the ballpark because so many people
were doing oh I felt so bad and we were
all nervous and anxious and but on you
go right you go on because it means
something to you because you really do
like it I agree are you an actress
yourself I am not I'm a writer you're a
writer I'm a writer so I do I do feel
the push but yeah